this is the field middle in a way it's
the dream of mathematicians but we would
never say it openly it would be
considered as very outrageous and the
best thing you have to do to get the
Fields Medal is to do some good work and
not thinking about it everyone watching
this is Professor of Alana's face medal
you won this yes but my name is they're
very discreet you know here is the date
2010 and here's my name it's very small
because you know we mathematicians are
small in front of the mathematical
accomplishment this is pure gold and
this is Archimedes maybe the greatest
mathematician of antiquity the
descriptions here are in Greek and Latin
language can't see as soon pectus mundo
quip a theory means some things like you
know to get above oneself and conquer
the world something like that which is
about mathematical accomplishment great
mathematical accomplishment you really
do things that you would not believe
yourself are possible and you have to
find it within you with the help of many
people this feed medal owes so so so
much to my collaborators - as a word for
my works in statistical physics study of
the qualitative properties of the gases
and the plasmas please look at the what
is on the other side because this also
is important congregate TX - to obey
mathematic e-up Skepta insignia trip
where it means something about the
mathematicians who have come from all
around the earth to give these to the
people who most deserve it something
like that and this is one thing with the
Fields Medal it's really an award from
the community and is attributing the
public ceremony in front of thousands of
mathematicians is given by the head of
state of the country in which this
conference is taking how did you get
yours from a president of India in 2010
yes
such memories here you may see that
something like is here and here
something like a cylinder and it's an
allusion to one of the most famous
theorems of Archimedes the identity of
the volume of the sphere and of the
cylinder in which you can inscribe the
sphere the outer cylinder how did you
find out you'd wanna when is the first
time you're told that you're going to
get the medal I was exactly here this
place and I was having an interview and
then the phone rings hello
and the voice was saying hello this is
Lazlo lavas from Budapest and then my
heart skipped a bit because you know I
knew Lazlo was the president of the
International mathematical Union so the
only person whom I knew to be on the
jury of the Fields Medal related to the
committee and so yes professor lavas
nice to hear you and then I have news
good news for you then you can think of
me becoming all white and so on and yes
like and then you wanna fill the middle
and then the car what did you share did
you make know as I says extraordinary as
ever a tirado I can't believe it it's
more believe such beautiful day
extraordinary Obama and so on and so
forth and then he explained me yes and
keys keep it strictly confidential it's
very important to keep the secrets on a
yes and then I shut down and acasio and
then I realized John Riis was there
couple of meters away ah did I make a
brick blender turns out you need not
maybe he did not speak English after all
the Fields Medal is often described as
sort of a Nobel Prize of mathematics so
it's like it's a big prize do you don't
deserve it or did you buy that point did
you think yeah I should get the Fields
Medal for this um we all have this
feeling at some moment that we don't
deserve it all most of us and often I
would say for given round the Fields
Medal there are those who do such an
amazing world that you know okay this
guy will get it and everybody knows it
like purel man it was clear was so
extraordinary that was clear he should
get it and there are people who did some
good stuff but then it's not clear you
know and it's partly a matter
appreciation and of luck and then this I
think that I was lucid another thing
that's famous about the Fields Medal and
different from the Nobel Prize is the
age limit what do you think about that
wrong it seems arbitrary there is some
dose of arbitrariness and particular and
the fact that changes the perspective
depending on your birth date but there
are many arbitrary rules in life you
know once I was discussing this with
when will my colleagues back in 2006
maybe in the International Congress of
mathematicians in Madrid enjoy saying
well it's unfair because this then
depends on your birthday too cetera your
chance to get it and he looked at me
with this little smile and said are you
saying that life is unfair you know has
so many rules and so much in life so you
should not strive for perfect you know
fairness makes no sense and it's good to
have a rule of age limitation because it
favors the young and historically it's
clear that the Fields Medal was
conceived as an encouragement rather
than a crowning achievement then it kind
of took the place in the media that
Nobel Prize you
because there was no nobel prize in math
now there is the other prize which in
some sense is cruiser-to-cruiser - Nobel
I would say that it's good to have this
age limit also it makes sure that people
who do something real great get honored
you know untime sometimes people for the
Nobel Prize you have to wait for 30
years sometimes they are dead and we say
okay the guy should really have got it
but now too late when you win the thing
that every mathematician dreams of
winning how do you keep motivating
yourself how do you keep doing good
mathematics and focus because what makes
you wake up in the morning and think I
want to make a new discovery because you
want to feel smell like you've done the
best thing you could do hey it's this
recurring question what makes you wake
up in the morning you know we all have
our missions - to do that we have to
complete and it would be very silly to
think that when you have won a crowning
achievement at the end of the mission
most of the time people get rewarded for
work which is not the one they've
dreamed of there are exceptions taken -
why's he sold his child dream the fam'ly
theorem but for most of us you know I
did not solve the question that were
most dear to my heart and most of us
rewarded we can say the same our big
problems the ones we are most motivated
about are still open so much to do but
if I had all this time there would be a
list that long of things that I really
would like to work on and at least four
projects of books but I would like to
write a real mathematician a true
mathematician at heart always keeps in
his heart issues that are extremely dear
to him and that he wants that she wants
to go on and to dig and to explore and
the real true mathematician
we can put these questions in the fridge
for twenty years and get back to them
after stayed with the same motivation
Andrew Wiles head for Mars Last Theorem
very famously what cédric Villani z' for
mars Last Theorem what's the one that
what's your what's your white whale
what's your you know what's your
great-great one that you can't crack
what would be your dream
this rule need to keep my heart for
myself until I solve it is it the
Riemann hypothesis wow it would be
lovely but no that one is not for me
that one would be for somebody else I
hope
that that is not the same thing as the
full kakeya problem because maybe as the
direction varies smoothly
maybe the pole would have to jump around
Lu the Riemann hypothesis be solved
Oh while cédric Villani is still alive I
would not take bit